Speaker 1: Well, it has happened, we have
been waiting for some signal and we've been
talking about it all week and last week, what
is the future of the Republican Party in the
United States?
Republicans have now canceled one of their
own, Liz Cheney, Republican congresswoman
from Wyoming.
Republicans have voted and she is out from
leadership.
And this is seen widely as a signal that the
trumping wing of the Republican Party is here
at least through 2020 two.
And depending on what happens in twenty twenty
two, it may persist beyond that or it may
not.
And we are going to have all of the different
details.
Understand that the context here is Republicans
claim to be against console culture.
And yet this movement to cancel one of their
own, Republican Congresswoman Liz Cheney,
is predicated on the fact that she admits,
accepts, realizes, use whatever word you want,
that Donald Trump lost the 2020 election.
That's what this is fundamentally about.
And House Republicans have voted to remove
her from her leadership role, believed that
she will be replaced by pro Trump.
Congresswoman Elise Stefanik.
That news, we may know that for sure.
By the time today's program is published,
we're recording it while a lot of this news
is breaking.
But the no confidence vote was expected today
for Liz Cheney, and it took place during a
closed door Republican conference meeting.
And we know that this is the anti cancel party
canceling one of their own for what really
should be a very uncontroversial.
It's not even a view.
I struggle to even say it's her view.
She simply accepts the fact.
It's like saying we've canceled someone because
of their opinion on gravity.
Like, well, no, I mean, you can either accept
how gravity works or you can not accept it,
but it doesn't change the reality.
That's fundamentally what we're talking about
here.
Liz Cheney has criticized Donald Trump for
spreading the lie that the 2020 election was
rigged against him.
It was not.
And Republicans are furious and they've wanted
her demoted for some period of weeks.
Now, arguably, this movement has been building
for several months and they would love for
her to lose her seat altogether.
Although from what I've recently heard, she
does plan to run for reelection in 2020.
To check out how some Republicans are framing
this here as Republican Congressman Jim Jordan
saying Liz Cheney defending free and fair
elections.
That's essentially what she did last night
on the floor of the House, conceding that
they lost those are called Democrat talking
points, according to Congressman Jim Jordan.
This is from Laura Ingraham's program on Fox
News last night.
Speaker 2: Committee.
Congressman, your thoughts on what you just
heard from Liz Cheney.
Speaker 3: You can't have the Republican conference
chair reciting Democrat talking points, especially
when gas prices are up 50 percent.
There's a crisis on the border and Democrats
are trying to federalize election law and
pack the United States Supreme Court.
That is not helpful.
That is the concern.
And that's why three months ago, there were
a number of us who wanted to make a change.
That change, in fact, will happen tomorrow,
Laura.
And I think that's a good thing for our party.
You want our party spokesperson to be in tune
with more than a single digit percentage of
the party.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, the things that
Jim Jordan cites there are all bogus.
And we've talked about most of them individually
already.
Gas prices are up for two reasons.
Number one, the resurgence of demand as we
come out of the pandemic.
There was a demand collapse last year.
Now demand is recovering.
And number two, there's this pipeline problem
that is both temporary but has nothing whatsoever
to do with Joe Biden.
So Jim Jordan is just making stuff up.
It has nothing to do with any of this.
They're just canceling someone.
That's all that's going on.
The crisis at the border.
We can we can fine tune to what degree there
is a problem at the border and there is one.
But the sudden Biden crisis has been something
ginned up by Republicans who didn't care about
the situation at the border when it was under
Donald Trump.
And it's all made up.
But the real story here is they say don't
cancel people for dissenting views.
We don't cancel people for dissenting views.
And here is a dissenting view, which is as
uncontroversial as they come.
The election result is real.
That's the view.
And Liz Cheney has been canceled.
Here's one other example.
Donald Trump's daughter in law, Lara Lara
Trump, this morning on Fox and Friends saying
Liz Cheney needs to go because her view that
Biden won doesn't represent what most of Republicans
believe in.
Lara Trump is right about that.
Most Republicans have fallen for this.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: Yeah, well, she really doesn't
represent, I think, the views of.
Most Republicans out there, the views of our
party.
Look, there are seventy five million Americans
out there that voted for President Donald
Trump that still had a lot of questions about
this election.
We can't just let it go.
We can't just sweep it under the rug.
And so whenever you stop representing the
party that, you know, when you're, again,
the third and leadership there, you really
probably shouldn't have a leadership role.
So we'll see, obviously, what happens.
I know they're going to vote on it, but I
think Elise Stefanik would be incredible.
She's been a great supporter of Republican
and conservative values, a great supporter
of my father in law.
So I'd be happy to see her take that position.
Speaker 1: This is really an issue of accepting
reality.
That's really what we're talking about here.
It's it's it's becoming almost more like a
mental health issue than a political issue.
It's a sort of psychosis that has taken hold.
And without praising Liz Cheney.
Right.
I mean, Liz Cheney is not a friend of the
left.
She's not a progressive.
I probably agree with her on essentially nothing.
But agreeing with her that Trump lost is sort
of like agreeing that we breathe the air of
which oxygen is a component.
Right?
I mean, it's not even a political thing.
What is Laura Trump know about anything?
She's a commentator because her husband is
the son of a former president.
What exactly are her credentials?
But she's right that most Republicans seem
unable to accept that Donald Trump simply
lost.
So on this one issue, Liz Cheney is correct.
She said last night in a speech on the floor
of the House that Donald Trump is a threat
to America.
That's true, she said.
Joe Biden one.
That's true.
She said the election is over, that the rule
of law and the constitutional process have
taken hold.
All of that is true.
These are uncontroversial things and Liz Cheney
is being punished for them.
This is how backwards the Republican Party
is right now.
And as they have removed her from her party
leadership role today, the Republican Party
is committing, in a sense, to the opposite
of what they claim to be about.
But more importantly, we've been wondering,
is 2022 going to be a continued Trump and
Republican year or not?
The answer appears to be that, yes, it will.
Many Republicans are not pleased with this
from outside of the House of Representatives.
And that's exactly what I want to talk about
next